The Unreal Engine offers developers handy libraries that can be used during the development
of their project.
These libraries combine common functionality that we may want to use in multiple parts
of our projects, so let's take a quick look at some of the libraries we have available
to us straight out of the box.
As we said, Unreal offers a wide range of static classes to provide easily accessible
and common functionality, such as lerping a value from A to B with a given alpha,
or a templated square value.
Some of these libraries are built in such a way that make them easy to expose the
functionality out to blueprint, and this is commonly done through the use of the UBlueprint
function library class, alongside sensible UFunction macros.
As well as function libraries, developers are given access to the FMath static set
of functions, which is a native only library that allows developers to make use of common
mathematical functions without needing to rewrite them from scratch.
These function libraries also give us access to gameplay functions that can be handy to
use.
For example, the Gameplay Statics library hosts a wide range of functions that allow
developers to spawn an actor from multiple sources, such as a blueprint pointer or a
T subclass.
Programmers can also leverage the blueprint function libraries to build their own set
of static functions that can allow other developers on the project to make use of
their own pieces of work.
By utilizing the reflection system, these functions can be made available to both programmers
in native and designers and artists in blueprint.